Washington, DC, gets blown up all the time —
in the movies.
But what if it happened for real?
Hopefully, we’ll never find out.
But federal emergency officials
have to prepare for the worst.
Emergency responders would have to deal with
shattered buildings, rubble-filled streets,
downed power lines, fried cell phones,
radioactive contamination, and casualties numbering in
the hundreds of thousands.
It would be a disaster beyond anything
ever seen in an American city -- certainly beyond
anything that emergency managers
have ever experienced.
So, to help them figure out what to expect
in such a catastrophe, researchers from Virginia
Tech university have built an entire digital DC
inside a computer — and have blown it up
over and over and over.
In an effort to make their model
as accurate as possible,
they start with the basic geography
of Washington.
Then they add in every building …
Every road…
Every power line…
Every hospital…
Even every cell tower.
Next, the modelers populate their virtual DC
with millions of digital people, known as ‘agents’.
These agents are like members of the crowd
in a computer-generated scene in a movie:
They can move around the landscape
and react to each other and their surroundings
in human-like ways.
But unlike CGI crowds,
each agent pursues its own goals.
they can switch between goals like ‘run’, ‘hide’,
‘help out’, and ‘find loved ones.’
Finally, the modelers simulate the effects
of a 10-kiloton nuclear bomb that explodes
on a Monday morning in May,
just a few blocks north of the White House.
They use standard models of blast effects
to estimate casualties and damage to buildings.
They use weather models to track the spread of fallout.
But they allow the agents
to react to the disaster as individuals.
This gives the agents’ bottom-up behavior
the kind of spontaneity that’s so often
seen in real life — and that is almost impossible
to model in any other way.
It also gives emergency managers
a much better handle on the
surprising and obstinate ways
that people often behave in a crisis.
For example, if the authorities warn everyone
to find shelter and stay there until the fallout
dies down, the model shows
that many people will ignore them.
Instead, they will be out on the roads,
desperately trying to pick up their kids from school,
or find missing spouses.
Many of them may even end up
traveling toward ground zero.
But the model also shows that the authorities
can minimize this chaos if they move quickly
to restore cell service: if people can verify
that their loved ones are safe, they are more
likely to stay where they are.
This disaster-response simulation is just
one example of what ‘agent-based’ models can do.
More and more real-world decision-makers
are using these models to plan new highways,
improve the flow of crowds in public places,
plan how to respond to epidemics —
or even minimize the chances of a stock market crash.